this is Tesco Toronto were reorganized
the way that some of its stores are run
and that's you've mentioned in that uh
sequence uh just now Jane they're
creating these new roles of shift
leaders which will replace some existing
uh management roles uh the other factor
of that the 350 localized moves that are
being made is essentially a closure of
Tesco's remaining uh hot and Delhi
counters in Outlets it's in a decline in
demand for those Services over recent
years and also they are closing eight
local pharmacies as well taking those
jobs in store and together with the
closure of an operations center in
Milton Keynes they also think that will
bring to a total some 350 rolls all
together now it's worth pointing out
Tesco making clear that not only will
there be some 1800 shift leader roles
created as a result of this upheaval
they currently have some 2 000 in-store
vacancies as well so net net it doesn't
really appear as though uh Tesco is
actually cutting its headcount it's it's
really reallocating roles and positions
now that may involve potentially some
workers suffering a cut in pay should
they switch from one of the older roles
to one of the newly created roles
there's a statement here from Jason
Terry he's the UK Republic of Ireland
chief executive of Tesco and Jason Tarry
says these are difficult decisions to
make but they are necessary to ensure we
remain focused on delivering value for
our customers wherever we can as well as
ensuring our store offer reflects what
our customers value the most our
priority is to support those colleagues
impact it and help find alternative
roles within our business from the
vacancies our newly created roles that
we have available now of course the
bigger backdrop to this is that all of
the supermarket operators are peddling
incredibly hard right now to prevent uh
having to pass on inflation costs that
they're seeing input cost inflation to
customers and trying to keep their
prices competitive and to that end we're
seeing a number of changes across the
industry right now only last week Asda
announced that it was making uh some 211
shift managers redundant and changing
the working hours of a further 4 100
employees across the business so it's an
incredibly difficult time I think the
bigger backdrop to this is that all of
the group grocery multiples are trying
to keep a lid on inflation where they
can and run themselves more efficiently
where possible